it's a summer first especially for
sophia especially for you regina summer
for her first camp her first boyfriend
her first really trying to get the lead
and the musical was this journey been
like for us so for so many firsts
oh this has been
this this whole entire show has been
my first as a high schooler because i
started the show when i was a freshman
um and so i really have experienced high
school through high school musical
musical the series every time we have
some sort of event um like the
homecoming or any sort of prom or
whatever it may be like those things
that only exist in high school i now get
to experience the show which is so much
fun for me but um
it just it's exciting to get to actually
live life through through a show that i
love so much with people that i love so
much
i love you there
so now dara we love you as coordinator
series but we also loving your tick
tocks
how much fun do you have on the platform
can we expect expect to see some fun
tick tocks from behind the scenes of
season three oh yes of course literally
i'm telling you i got so much tea out i
was waiting i was so scared that i was
gonna release it by accident i was like
because you know tick tock change their
settings so i was like oh god
but uh yeah i got a lot of tea a lot of
content and i can't wait to share with
everybody especially with all you know
the new people and everything it was
really fun
and you guys have so many major
superstars and get as guest roles this
season jojo siwa jesse tyler ferguson
how much fun was i having jojo on set
because i feel like she would fit in
this cast perfectly
yeah i think dara you might have gone to
hang out with her a little bit more than
i did but
or maybe not but
it's actually
no because it's actually so funny
because i had i had food poisoning that
day
and no cause literally tmi but like i
was like she was so nice about it too
she was like are you okay are you okay
i'm up here like yeah i'm like such a
huge fan and i'm just like going like
this
like with my stomach but she was
literally the sweetest person ever so
talented and i mean the scenes that
she's in is just
perfection and i couldn't have asked for
a better better new addition amazing
person mm-hmm i completely agree i
totally forgot that you had food with me
that day but now i remember
you're like struggling
you pulled through it was tight i was
like why every year every season
what the season okay got it
it was so nice though jojo was so so
wonderful um i had actually met her
years and years or years ago um on like
dance moms and like doing stuff on that
which was like so long ago and um and
now getting to meet her again when we're
in very different places was really
exciting and she's so so nice um also
like jason jason earls he was our
dialogue coach for the first two seasons
so getting to work alongside him on
screen in front of the camera was so
much fun like we all adore jason so that
was definitely a highlight for me no i
definitely feel like this this um since
it's a camp it definitely give it like a
camp vibe did it feel like that while
filming
yeah i've never been to camp garrett
have you been to a camp before yes i was
a camp counselor
i had never been so it was truly like
camp for me and then it's so funny i've
now after the show stopped filming i've
gone to three different camps and so i
went into it with the idea of like
this is going to be like high school
musical camp
it was not like guys from youtube camp
but it was still super fun it's just
like
my experiences on the show are truly
what i expect from life and life is
always so different
oh no i feel that literally as a cam
counselor it was like so much fun but
like so scared to because you have all
these little kids and they're like hey
can i do this can i do this and you're
in the middle like of the woods and
you're like uh you're scared yourself
but you can't show it so it's like yeah
of course you can like go see that tree
okay quickly guys can you guys say the
ackerman of the show titled correctly
it's just some
tmts
why did i think about it i know it
no i'm like a little scared hsn tmts
yeah yeah perfect guys a plus anyways
thank you so much for your time i hope
you have a lovely day
you